the jurogan experience when things get
you know someone's in my face barking
about something or you know you get
in the art world you get these people
that are really big pants but
they would cower if you stood up what do
you mean in the art world you know
yeah publishers you get gallery owners
that are going to bark at you and tell
you the way it is and you're going to
do this really oh yeah oh yeah really or
art world oh telling you man tell me
just i've dealt with gallery owners who
are
like super bullies who are like you're
going to do this i need this now and
you're going to get it today tomorrow
and you talk to you like all the time
and you go um
i'm probably not going to do any of that
and the thing is i like to i like to be
super calm
and it's almost like mine jiu jitsu or
where i go
all that huffing and puffing you're
doing doesn't affect me one bit
um if you want to go to sleep i can
accommodate that
but we're not going to go down that road
and and you know i mean
this thing that's interesting and they
would never have thought that the art
it can be a dirty world i've had
galleries that knocked me off my own
galleries
start ripping me off and producing work
of mine out the back door
and signing my name like making prints
of your [ __ ] right that's right
wow one fake signing your name yep yep
yep
yep caught them caught them and then
they said oh
no we got that from china and and we're
suing you
and they come after me they got it from
china yeah they would make up [ __ ] it
was all made up right
we caught them and where was this
gallery it was in uh huntington beach
really and uh we uh
we caught them and we shut it down hard
and then they flipped the script and
that that's when it was interesting
because
we were getting calls from a lot of
media and press and they were they're
asking me like oh
you've been referred to as uh you and
your band of thugs went down
and took all your art right so what i
did is i flipped it i said
i like that title i'm gonna do a
painting called band of thugs
and i did this like old mobster 30s
painting of all these dudes and thugs
band of thugs and i'm gonna make money
off that and and uh
you know it was uh did you have to go
down there and get your art
oh yeah i went and took everything i got
my art back well i'm taking all of it
out of here
you're no longer a todd white gallery
you're done
and it's soon with it and died after
that but uh it
drug out illegal problems and legal
cases and how long did it last
about a year and a half there it is look
at that
that's it look at the guy missing an eye
oh wow just that's a band of thugs right
you want a band of thugs there it is
that's great and uh
that's like some uh what's that [ __ ]
guy uh
the butcher oh yeah bill the butcher
build a butcher from
gangs in new york things in new york
king of new york yeah go to that [ __ ]
build a butcher
i mean that is kind of how they're
they're they're looking at they're
painted like
old-timey bad people yeah
yeah it was funny because uh this vanity
fair did an article on it and uh
and and they totally it's funny because
vanity fair did an article on what
the whole scam and the whole [ __ ]
yeah because it was it made a lot of you
know she sold
a couple hundred thousand dollars in
fake art out there she sold it across
the international
as a woman yeah i was a woman and
international lines and
and it it it it went so she ripped you
off to the tune of a couple hundred
thousand bucks oh yeah
yeah wow and it was funny because uh
you know when it all came out and it was
all court cases and stuff i had i had
galleries calling me because i got
scared like oh no
i had galleries calling me and they're
like hey we want to carry you
this is 2000 got 12.
hey we want to carry you we want to and
i thought was this weird like all this
bad stuff's happening but why so the guy
calls me back up art publisher calls me
and he goes
let me get this right you're asking me
how come guys want to carry you
when this is shit's going on she made
you de niro in a scorsese movie and
you're wondering why
and i was like he goes play it up live
up to it go ahead go
oh yeah you can carry me and you know
what'll happen if you don't pay on time
oh no and so it was just the
ridiculousness and uh but it you know
look
truth prevailed and it worked out and
they're gone and i'm still thriving
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience